I need something for my hair.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then probably the final point that I want to touch on is our African institutions.
[SPEAKER_02]: Our African institutions are built in such a way that they are so much out of touch with the evolving dynamics of the world.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so we need to reform them, restructure them, make them more in line with the evolving dynamics of the world.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to push you a bit on that.
[SPEAKER_02]: We've been raising these same challenges.
[SPEAKER_05]: for 20 years.
[SPEAKER_05]: You know, for 20 years we've been talking about the great youth of Africa, the great diaspora opportunities.
[SPEAKER_05]: And every time we say, why is not progress?
[SPEAKER_05]: And we talk about institutions, we talk about citizens, we talk about politics.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why can we not shift that bottleneck?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the biggest challenge about this is
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't want to say there's a societal challenge, but to share that, we need a very Afrocentric approach to that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because remember that across the continent, the majority of countries are still using these post-colonial structures that really do not work for us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Take for instance our educational system.
[SPEAKER_02]: We keep talking about decolonization of education and so on and so forth.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why do we speak about this?
[SPEAKER_02]: We do because the educational system teaches us and trains us to work for a system.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so we are now beginning to build an entrepreneurial and startup ecosystem in a way that fits into the African context.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think that is one of the things that we need to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: How do we train these young people in a way that they depart from the historic educational system that trains you to only work for
[SPEAKER_02]: I use this example at every time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why is it that those that speak the most fancy English in our communities are seen as the most independent?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because the foreign independent were interpreters of all those.
[SPEAKER_02]: They were interpreters of the colonialist and the societies for the grassroots.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so, of course, if you were an interpreter between law people and materialists, that's a problem.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, 60 years down the line,
[SPEAKER_02]: What do we do?
[SPEAKER_02]: We go into a society and those that meet the best needs are seen as the most intelligent.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if you want to evaluate the real impact of what they do, you don't find that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so I think that we need that, that started by our educational system because that's where the issue is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Second, moving beyond the education system is really to shift focus on what drives development and what creates the impact.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I try to use this example every day.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you go to my small village in the northern part of Ghana, the guy that fabricates the cold pot for cooking every day, the guy that creates the plow for the bullocks is not recognized.
[SPEAKER_02]: But to feed the society, you need these guys to do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But then you find another person who lives in Accra, and all he does is eat very big English, a secretary in maybe a minister's office, and is the most celebrated person in the society.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, these are the structural issues that we need to deal with.
[SPEAKER_02]: But to deal with that, those of us in this room that are beneficiaries of this leverage might be willing to shift from that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's where the AOTB and other institutions come.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I've mentioned this more than two minutes, that the kind of investment that is made in our respective countries
[SPEAKER_02]: must be made in the way that the grassroots are direct beneficiaries of those investments.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that when you, when the AFPG of the welfare gives the Republic of Ghana or Cote d'Ivoire a hundred million, and the entire hundred million is into consultancies, is into just technical meetings and workshops, either than giving the money to the young person that lives in Yangtze River that has been a cashless farm for X time.
[SPEAKER_02]: By the time we didn't come to do monetary evaluation and how that $100 million was expended, it's still in Abidjan.
[SPEAKER_02]: And nobody knows what happened.
[SPEAKER_02]: But then, in the records of AFDB, they've given good before $100 billion.
[SPEAKER_02]: And for economic development and transformation, what Alec's first task was, he transformed those picking the fussy Indians into the most frustrated students in the city.
[SPEAKER_02]: So once we don't address these fundamental bottlenecks, then we'll keep moving in circles.
[SPEAKER_02]: of saying, why are you not moving?
[SPEAKER_02]: And let me conclude by saying this.
[SPEAKER_02]: The young people of this continent are innovative.
[SPEAKER_02]: The young people of this continent are very hardworking.
[SPEAKER_02]: The difference and why you do not feel the young people of this continent is because they are serious bottlenecks from the factory regimes to where the action actually is.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we don't feel the action because at the end of the day,
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'd like to come to you with the same question, but if possible, I'd like to probe a bit.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ben talked about one of the biggest challenges of us making this transition from identifying these challenges to actually moving it is the lack of an Afrocentric approach.
[SPEAKER_05]: You sit at the nexus of the international, you know, the institutions that he said are not working for Africa and the diaspora who want to come back.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'd love you to talk about that as you answer your question, please.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you, everyone.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you for inviting me.
[SPEAKER_03]: I am going to think a little bit of a different approach to this, and I'm going to speak about this from a diaspora perspective.
But I also want to talk from the narrative perspective and reality.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, from Jen's perspective, I think, for me, what makes us wake up every day in the morning to this work for the last 50 years has been the belief that 60% of the population of Africa is a force for good.
[SPEAKER_03]: And if it is a force for good, then we must invest in that good.
[SPEAKER_03]: It will take time, but we need to invest.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think the God that we see is not a knowledge God.
[SPEAKER_03]: It is not an intention God.
[SPEAKER_03]: It is not an ambition God.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think it's an infrastructure God.
[SPEAKER_03]: But the biggest one is a trust God.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think we need to build trust.
[SPEAKER_03]: And what I can say is that the next one leaves their country for many reasons.
[SPEAKER_03]: We migrate for many, many reasons.
[SPEAKER_03]: And of one of the many reasons, we leave the very country that we were born, we love, we are committed to it, nothing about that.
[SPEAKER_03]: And for me, it's everything.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know everything there as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: I left Asmara in 1984.
[SPEAKER_03]: It was terrible.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I don't think anything that can happen worse to me than this.
[SPEAKER_03]: At the time, I thought the world was just closing out for me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because one of these pieces was leaving an opportunity behind.
[SPEAKER_03]: But what I didn't know was the opportunity that was also always there for me.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I must take the opportunity one day.
[SPEAKER_03]: But when we leave our places, I think we're going to miss a lot of opportunities, a lot of possibilities.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I think my classes would have been better if I had been in a peaceful society.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think from the dashboard when you mention class is that we left because of lack of class.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we can think of it that way.
[SPEAKER_03]: But when we pass, we are the most generous people to give back.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'll bring this back to the university.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are we going to leapfrog
[SPEAKER_03]: and try to get the same principle that my parents waited for so many years to get landline, but then I went back in the early 2000s and everybody had a mobile phone.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you think of systems change in that way, we must change that system that will enable the 60% of the composition that my brother was talking about to thrive.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think the other gap that we're seeing is also connectedness to each other.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I think we're talking about race separation.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why do we say that?
[SPEAKER_03]: It seems like we won't have to probably come back home.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I think we have the capability to mentor, to train, to invest in my country or in other countries that might do.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's another thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: One of the greatest hindrances we see is we're still very nationalistic human beings.
[SPEAKER_03]: We are attuned to the country where we come from.
[SPEAKER_03]: But Africa is an incongruent continent of 54 countries.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have a home where we can invest where we see an investment opportunity, whether it's in the youth, whether it's an investment that we are interested in.
[SPEAKER_03]: And how do we make that happen?
[SPEAKER_03]: Trust is the key to this.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I will end by saying, almost hopefully not,
[SPEAKER_03]: There are so many amazing stories that are happening in certain value-added based, young Africans who have created systems that is not necessarily an investment from the likes of NVIDIA.
[SPEAKER_03]: NVIDIA has now a partnership with NVIDIA, NVIDIA's knowledge exchange platform.
[SPEAKER_03]: These are inside technologies, all these are being built
[SPEAKER_03]: So why are people looking at the continent?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because of the people.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's 60% of the population for the continent.
[SPEAKER_03]: And so in 2015, it was going to be the largest continent in the world, one in four around the world, to be added.
[SPEAKER_03]: But what people ask is, are we going to take this as an opportunity?
[SPEAKER_03]: And why is it being added within the system sometimes?
[SPEAKER_05]: I really like the point you raise on trust.
[SPEAKER_05]: So when I think of the diaspora and how they invest in the continent, you know, my parents' generation were very much, you know, send money home, and they came back, they tried to come back in your time, and some managed to do it, others didn't.
[SPEAKER_05]: Second generations like me come back much earlier.
[SPEAKER_05]: Some come and stay, others don't.
[SPEAKER_00]: But interestingly, I've seen second and third generation Africans come back much, much younger.
Okay?
Just help me understand that just deficit.
[SPEAKER_05]: Because when you talk about the skills and the opportunities, you know, these are people that could bring a lot back home.
[SPEAKER_05]: What is that ?
[SPEAKER_03]: So the task I'm going to put from institutional and maybe narrative, so I'll just say that instead of if you say to a major investor, if you invest in a company, you would be happy to give a certain million dollars.
[SPEAKER_03]: Africa is not ready for billion dollars of investment.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I refuse to accept that, because that's not true.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you've got that narrative issue that's also hindering us.
[SPEAKER_03]: And our own bias for our narrative is also sometimes very critical.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we are so good at trusting, as I said earlier, to our own community, from those that we know and grew up with, which is actually acceptable.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'll give you an example of that successful, of that,
[SPEAKER_03]: There are two in our dance club.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm happy to be with anyone who's interested in their stories.
[SPEAKER_03]: One of them is creating an active knowledge company in Rwanda.
[SPEAKER_03]: 80% of this funding came from who?
[SPEAKER_03]: The dance club.
[SPEAKER_05]: These are fantastic dance clubs who are doing this.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to give you another one from the Nigerian community in Houston.
[SPEAKER_03]: There are a few Nigerians in Texas who could listen to this.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is very important.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then we need to imagine what would that look like if we can all do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then each group, say there are about 20 of them, for 50,000 dollars each, if you want to count, would they then make it competitive for Nigerians from the diaspora to compete to get that money?
[SPEAKER_03]: So imagine if the whole bank, the African Development Bank, can organize us systematically to be able to put that money in the hands of
[SPEAKER_03]: Not only the few who built that based on relationship that I was able to get the money from, what about the youth that we're talking about and who have the capacity, the knowledge, the ambition, the ability, and yet they have no access to that money?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think we need to imagine that that's what trust does.
[SPEAKER_03]: Trust does, I know you, so I'll give you the money.
[SPEAKER_03]: What about the other person?
[SPEAKER_03]: who doesn't know me, who has no access to me, that's where African Development Bank comes.
[SPEAKER_03]: It builds the trust-based fund within other people from the continent.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not because of who they are and where they came from and that they know someone, but because of their capability, they will be able to access to that fund.
[SPEAKER_03]: We must make that possible.
[SPEAKER_03]: Otherwise, I can tell you, from the diaspora side, we're doing fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because we do relate about $100 billion to the continent every year.
[SPEAKER_03]: which is not always scalable, because it's transactional.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's between me and my family.
[SPEAKER_03]: And whatever you do with that money, I'm not asking you to give me a return on my investment.
[SPEAKER_03]: But we are also investing in the person we know is just too small and too slow.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need to go fast, and we need to do this based on trust.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we have to have an institution
[SPEAKER_03]: but we can pass on to people our money, and I'm going to end by saying the good news.
[SPEAKER_03]: There is about 5 billion per year of savings from the dance floor only in the United States alone.
[SPEAKER_03]: APN is asking, when we created the Beyond Relatances, we weren't asking people not to send money home.
[SPEAKER_03]: We were asking ourselves, can we put some of our savings into an investment that is going to enable
[SPEAKER_03]: our community, our youth, to accelerate and scale.
[SPEAKER_03]: So there's hope and there's a possibility.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now, Ty, I'd like to come back to you with the same question.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now, Alice talked a lot about the ecosystem and the need to build a strong ecosystem.
[SPEAKER_05]: So as you're reflecting on the question, I would love to hear from you why we are struggling
[SPEAKER_05]: to build that ecosystem from the young people that you are engaged with.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why do you think you are striving to build that ecosystem?
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you so much, Dr. Mavis.
[SPEAKER_04]: And thank you also, I think, particularly to the African Development Bank for inviting me.
[SPEAKER_04]: I appreciate it because I'm a practical radical.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm an activist.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we're not really participating in those conversations about the economy.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm also a Gen Z, and I'm a pragmatic African futurist.
[SPEAKER_04]: That said, I wanted to start by pointing out some of the real issues that an African Gen Z, a young person in Africa, currently has to grapple with, and I'm going to centralize them around the economic questions, and particularly the material conditions of an African Gen Z.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's very, very important for us to understand that we are living in a world that is gradually becoming wealthier and more prosperous.
[SPEAKER_04]: But this very same world has produced unprecedented amounts of extreme poverty.
[SPEAKER_04]: So while in the world today we have a trillionaire, quite literally in this lifetime, the world's economy is big enough that we were able to have a trillionaire.
[SPEAKER_04]: We also have people that are living in active poverty, and unfortunately,
[SPEAKER_04]: many of those are black and brown people.
[SPEAKER_04]: They are people with a global majority and people with a global self that are leading up to poverty.
[SPEAKER_04]: And most of these also are young people.
[SPEAKER_04]: So a lot of the questions we are seeing around the migration issues, a lot of the issues that we see about young people drowning in the Mediterranean to try and go to Europe, we must, in essence, ask ourselves, what is it that is so unbearable and unbearable on the continent that the person is willing to risk drowning
[SPEAKER_04]: What is the aspiration, what is the fundamental goal, what is the desire of the human condition, the human spirit, the people of this particular place, for them to do what they have to do, and that is the best provider.
[SPEAKER_04]: These are people that have an unrelenting and unfuturing will and desire to be and do more.
[SPEAKER_04]: It is the insatiable human desire to have access to opportunity and to explore the very fundamentals of what they can become.
[SPEAKER_04]: and that is the actualization of their potential.
[SPEAKER_04]: But for a lot of African youth at this particular moment in history, they will never be able to leave up to the highs of their potential and their capabilities and their capacities because we have built systems that reproduce human misery, systems that manufacture poverty, and systems that make a radical insistence to concentrate wealth and capital on what we want to be a better country.
[SPEAKER_04]: So my conversation today in response to your question is the radical insistence on capital that actually works for people.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is where, if you forget anything else, please remember this.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're not having conversations around the floor of capital.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're not having conversations around building businesses because it's a nice tab.
[SPEAKER_04]: We have entrepreneurs that are extremely wealthy.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a good thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not at all.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's really about, does this trickle down to the people who are marginal?
[SPEAKER_04]: to the women, to youth, the persons with disabilities, the people in rural areas.
[SPEAKER_04]: Is this trickling down into our education systems, our education infrastructure?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is this trickling down to the people that need medical care?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is this trickling down to the people that need access to essential services?
[SPEAKER_04]: This is why we have these conversations about capital.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I do think when we talk about capital, capitalism in particular, it is good for all creation, but not necessarily for me.
[SPEAKER_04]: good with what distribution.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I think that is the critical question we need to ask as Africans with regards to how we build better systems that are particularly better with what distributions.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, to end, I just wanted to state that there are certain things that we must really become reflective about, but particularly in the context of Pan-Africanism.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I'd like to see African development back.
[SPEAKER_04]: The context of Pan-Africanism is that
[SPEAKER_04]: is a fundamental reflection of the aspiration of the dignity of the African.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's a critical conversation into the dignity of an African.
[SPEAKER_04]: And we can never have dignity if our economics is not rooted in this idea that young Africans or people who are Africans in general
[SPEAKER_04]: must lead to the moment where they have fundamental rights, where there is justice, where we have democratic institutions.
[SPEAKER_04]: And mind you, this conversation around democracy is not about American democracy or British democracy or French democracy, because all of those democracies have to be different.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's about African democracies.
[SPEAKER_04]: We must believe in a society where we think about ourselves culturally.
[SPEAKER_04]: We look at our context.
[SPEAKER_04]: We look at our history, our roots.
[SPEAKER_04]: our indigenous ideas and beliefs that come up with democracies that work for us, that encompass our cultural beliefs, that encompass who we are as a people, but still they must be democracies.
[SPEAKER_04]: The very essence of insisting that people must have the fundamental capabilities to express themselves without feeling that someone will come knocking on their door.
[SPEAKER_04]: The very belief that people must be able to run businesses in environments where the judiciary actually works.
[SPEAKER_04]: that if you have a dispute that you go to court, that would be a fair proceeding.
[SPEAKER_04]: Not that they would get a call from someone who's a higher up.
[SPEAKER_04]: And even if I run the business, and still to say I was the one who was fairly entitled to a decision that was supposed to be my favor, but because the judiciary is compromised, it does not work, someone else came at it.
[SPEAKER_04]: If we continue to do business in that way, we as Africans cannot progress.
[SPEAKER_04]: So this radical insistence on building systems that work for people, systems that manufacture environments that advance human potential, is something that we cannot move away from, even as we talk about economics, about capital.
[SPEAKER_04]: Systems that ensure that the African has healthcare, the African has education, the African has the basic necessities that we need to be a full and dignified human being.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is the insistence of what development actually should be and what countries should actually focus on in Africa.
[SPEAKER_04]: So to lend, I would just say that we need to really focus on integration.
[SPEAKER_04]: And this particular integration has to start from the realization that perhaps the African Union as an entity might be too big to facilitate this integration, though it is important.
[SPEAKER_04]: But maybe we might want to centralize on the BRICS, the regional economic bodies, the scientific efforts, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_04]: And this particular group, I think what we must concentrate on is particularly first to begin with, linguistic integration.
[SPEAKER_04]: Particularly Afro-linguistic integration.
[SPEAKER_04]: We have other forms of foreign, francophone, all that is part of extension .
[SPEAKER_04]: How about we have Afroform?
[SPEAKER_04]: How about we as Africans pick one African language that we want to be met in the different parts of the continent?
[SPEAKER_04]: so that we have our own language.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is for me, for instance.
[SPEAKER_04]: We all agree that people can learn other languages, but everyone in the country must mix with me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Because if we have language integration, it means that a person in South Africa, in Cape Town, can go to Cairo and still be able to connect and communicate.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that opens limitless possibilities in the context of academia, in the context of philosophy, in the context of cultural exchange, in the context of business.
[SPEAKER_04]: The next thing that is very critical is to deal with these issues around visas and the free movement of the African person.
[SPEAKER_04]: Africans live more freely on the continent.
[SPEAKER_04]: It goes without saying.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm utterly shocked that a little bit more than 15, 30 visas every rich African to move across the continent.
[SPEAKER_04]: What about that ?
[SPEAKER_04]: So we must really emphasize the issues around the free movement of people as much as we assist in the free movement.
[SPEAKER_04]: The last thing that we then have to really specialize with regards to integration is economic integration.
[SPEAKER_04]: We must train with each other.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I think it is repetitive, it's rhetorical, it's sometimes repeated.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the biggest barrier we have experienced with regards to this particular integration is really an initial crisis.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I would insist that we invent it.
[SPEAKER_04]: We need leaders who are able to prioritize the well-being and welfare of the African-American, recognizing that it is much, much more difficult for small African-American communities to be connected with the global stage, whereas if we come together as a million people, we are able to do that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'm just going to ask you very quickly, and with just one sentence.
[SPEAKER_05]: You said you were in radical tendency, and in your responses, I noticed some radical statements in there.
[SPEAKER_05]: Some of them are great, I mean, some of them are issues that we discuss all the time, but one of which we're dealing, what's my good answer?
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'm just gonna be a provocative Gen X and come back to you on a question.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, one of the things that I hear a lot when I talk to
[SPEAKER_05]: policymakers and leaders is that, ugh, these Gen Z people, they don't understand the complications we have to navigate, they're not realistic, they, you know, they see all this TikTok, and they're in a hurry to make money quick, blah, blah, blah.
[SPEAKER_05]: They really raise a powerful challenge to policymakers.
[SPEAKER_05]: How, just in one sentence, how would you respond to that question of, you don't understand the complexities, and
[SPEAKER_05]: you are in too much of a hurry to get to the top.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, thank you very much for that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm quite certain that it is always a generational consternation.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm very sure that when most people were young, their elders would say the same about them.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, it's totally understandable that they would have those sentiments.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I do suspect that Gen Alpha might have those same sentiments about Gen Z.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, I think it's really a generational issue.
[SPEAKER_04]: I would like to actually say that, you know, those people, their observation with regards to the agency and the refugees are in a rush.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think that their outlook is, in many respects, too.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I think it is also an inquisition on perspective, trying to understand where that is coming from.
[SPEAKER_04]: As a Gen Z, you must understand that Gen Zs in particular, if you have kids that are in their 20s, et cetera, we have a common age in the world in which the entry requirements are much higher, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: So I think of my mother.
[SPEAKER_04]: She could, with an ordinary level certificate, get a job in a bank.
[SPEAKER_04]: And in a couple of years, she could buy a house in a car with an ordinary level certificate.
[SPEAKER_04]: But for our generation, even with a master's certificate,
[SPEAKER_04]: we might not still be able to have a dignified existence.
[SPEAKER_04]: So we've come of age in a world where we have systems that require more from us and deliver less than we used to for past generations.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that in itself is consistent in terms of why Gen Z's sometimes want to be rushing, because we are recognizing that a lot of
[SPEAKER_04]: the things that we have experienced are things that past generations have not experienced.
[SPEAKER_04]: And a lot of the things that are limiting to us are things that were not limiting to the past generations.
And these things are pretty systemic and they are structural.
Over time, the system has begun to close.
And the fundamental truth about this is we need a radical shift in the context of systems destruction and systems reform.
[SPEAKER_04]: Back in the day, systems sometimes actually worked for people.
[SPEAKER_04]: When you saw a big advert on a billboard where a man was saying that we want to partner with you to help you build your home, they meant it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nowadays, it's correct.
[SPEAKER_04]: You might not get that home from the back because it is quite expensive, it is quite expensive.
[SPEAKER_04]: So this is the generation that we belong to.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I would say that yes, young people in a rush, yes, we might not understand the practicalities of the system and how slow it can be.
[SPEAKER_04]: But the emphasis is always to say that we need to make certain that we reform the systems to be more just and fair, so that whatever we put in has a fair and equal reward, much like we had in the past generations.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: So at this stage, I believe we have Monsieur Aziz Konate on the line.
[SPEAKER_05]: And he is the president of the Cote d'Ivoire Federation of Young Entrepreneurs.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mustia, are you online?
[SPEAKER_05]: Is he online?
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, excellent.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mustia, so I have a question for you.
[SPEAKER_05]: You've been listening to your colleagues on the panel.
[SPEAKER_05]: So beyond access to finance, what other binding constraints must be urgently dismantled to enable youth-led enterprises
[SPEAKER_05]: to anchor themselves in regional value chains.
Can you hear me?
Monsieur, can you hear me?
[SPEAKER_05]: Did you hear the question?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, you can speak in French.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, you want the question in French.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, who's a French speaker who can do a good translation for me?
[SPEAKER_05]: Can you help me?
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, can you please change your Zoom to French so that you can hear the question translated for you?
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you have it?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, we are in Paris.
[SPEAKER_05]: There has to be a translator for me here.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm a terrible Anglophone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mr. Comaté, can you hear me please?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, very good.
[SPEAKER_00]: So the question is, beyond access to funding, what constraints, whether they are institutional or market regulation constraints,
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_01]: department.
[SPEAKER_01]: For example, here in Côte d'Ivoire, we know that in Bonitou, we have all the families that we call the plantations that there are.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would like these signals that come from Bonitou to be transmitted, for example, to Ghana, to Mali, to Senegal, and so on, by these values consumed.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that this is an important element.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would like our states, since the production of the products that we produce,
[SPEAKER_01]: We don't know if we have enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we can even say that when we are in the space, when we are in the United States, we have a lot of entrepreneurs who come here, who come to have opportunities, who come here to work in their markets.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's an international adventure.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's communication.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can't...
[SPEAKER_01]: to buy what we do not know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Beyond that, there are small businesses that do not have the knowledge to manage the big market.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, it would be interesting to communicate with other people that, for example, when we find ourselves in an embassy in Ghana, in the Côte d'Ivoire in Ghana, for example, we can have a list of businesses in the Ivorian region
[SPEAKER_01]: to transform and that if I want to invest in Ghana, I can go to this ambassador and tell him, I came to Ghana, I want to invest and the ambassador is able to tell him, there were market decisions that were made and in Côte d'Ivoire, here is a word, do not hesitate and here, here are the two people, here are the customer advice, here are the companies that we want to put you in contact with,
[SPEAKER_01]: Here is a market study that shows that we have contacted one and a half people.
[SPEAKER_01]: Here are the statistics and statistics.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that allows you to go, maybe, in this long period of time, to go in a group.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you also have to understand that the companies have the same sector of expertise that you can consult in the market statistics as they do, maybe, in Chardonnay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because they are still in business, so that these companies can attract other markets.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you very much, Ben.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'd like to come to you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Ben raises a really valid point around being able to build visual money chains and how our governments can facilitate this through embassies, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now, you're in the diaspora, and you want to invest in, you talked about investing in funds, investing in entrepreneurship, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_05]: How easy do you find it to work with our African government and our African embassies to really promote the kind of connectivity that Ben is talking about between diaspora and African countries?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's wonderful, so thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to take a little bit of a step back into making this festival and just give an example of what worked and what didn't work.
[SPEAKER_03]: Our embassies
[SPEAKER_03]: In Washington, D.C., in 2023 or 22, during the Apple Year Summit, there was a convening that was put together to really understand the diplomatic core within the Washington, D.C. area.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you have to understand, I am speaking from a U.S. perspective because that's where I'm based.
[SPEAKER_03]: So majority of all embassies are in Washington, D.C., but we have consulate offices throughout different states within the country.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think where we are having the lack of connectedness to the dance floor and the embassies is, what I think is because there is not a dedicated, if there are, there are a few of them and I can count them by my fingers, there is no connected effort and systemic effort
[SPEAKER_03]: by the embassies, to actually learn from other countries, to mobilize, engage, and enable the banks to actually do the things they know how to do, which is to invest, to train, to educate.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have not given that opportunity.
[SPEAKER_03]: That system needs to change.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'll bring back to an example of, this might be helpful to those of you who have that kind of capacity to help us make it work.
[SPEAKER_03]: The Indian government
[SPEAKER_03]: This is very important.
[SPEAKER_03]: In the 1990s, they realized that the economy was going down, and who was coming back to save India?
[SPEAKER_03]: The Indian diaspora.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can read this.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's very well researched.
[SPEAKER_03]: Transformative economic development of any country in a very short period of time is the diaspora.
[SPEAKER_03]: How did that happen?
[SPEAKER_03]: I start to begin because I was trying to build African diaspora network.
[SPEAKER_03]: They created a diaspora engagement attachment or officer within every embassy whose job it is was to connect, to drive unites as a diaspora.
[SPEAKER_03]: He was the first part of India.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're doing this kind of investment.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need help.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can you help us?
[SPEAKER_03]: Can you connect us again?
[SPEAKER_03]: The rest is history.
[SPEAKER_03]: Today, the largest investor, enabler, talk about race and tradition.
[SPEAKER_03]: India is an incredible example.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can go on to other countries.
[SPEAKER_03]: The reason we think what is India when we talk about Africa is why?
[SPEAKER_03]: 1.2 billion people, similar to that of the continent.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, India is a country, and so is Africa for me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Africa is my country.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's just only a continent.
[SPEAKER_03]: It is one Africa that has the capability to do the same thing
[SPEAKER_03]: Look at India also.
[SPEAKER_03]: Extremely complicated, complex regional tribal, whatever you call it, division.
[SPEAKER_03]: And yet they found a way to mobilize and to really make sure that the diaspora is heavily engaged in that country.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can go on into what they've done.
[SPEAKER_03]: But that question is an incredible question.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's a timely question.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it's something part of the bigger infrastructure that we need to change.
[SPEAKER_03]: When we talk about the role of the government, it starts with the emissaries.
[SPEAKER_03]: I hope that answers your question.
[SPEAKER_05]: It does, it does.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now, I have a lot more questions for the panel, but I don't want to be too selfish.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'd like to turn to the audience to see if anybody has a question.
[SPEAKER_05]: If you don't, I'll just continue to be selfish.
[SPEAKER_05]: But does anybody have a question for the panelists?
No?
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so can I continue then?
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'd like to come to you, Ben.
[SPEAKER_05]: You know, early on, one of the things that Mamatai said was the need for leadership.
[SPEAKER_05]: You know, we need strong leaders to drive the building of this ecosystem and to navigate the inequality and disconnection
[SPEAKER_05]: between systems, institutions, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_05]: How do you think, but that leadership doesn't just sit with policymakers, it sits with all of us.
[SPEAKER_05]: How do you think African youth organizations can move beyond advocacy to become practical platforms for leadership development?
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, first we need to
[SPEAKER_02]: the new development ecosystem in Africa.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that's very, very important.
[SPEAKER_02]: And how it's going to be there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then second, we need to see this ecosystem that we have designed, what is it intended to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: And are the stakeholders that are supposed to work with the new development ecosystem doing what they are supposed to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: And then the third thing that we need to look at, how coordinated are the young people in their institutions, the new development ecosystem, and our states?
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'll start off by saying this.
[SPEAKER_02]: In 2006, the head of states adopted the advocate in charge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Article 12 says that every member state should set up a national coordinating mechanism.
[SPEAKER_02]: They felt short of telling us what the configuration of that coordinating mechanism should look like, so they got into politics.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, but do we have the institutions?
[SPEAKER_02]: We do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Currently, we have 47 national youth councils and international countries in the whole of the country.
[SPEAKER_02]: And in the remaining countries that do not, they have coordinating points at the ministries
[SPEAKER_02]: in their respective universities.
[SPEAKER_02]: How do we utilize these structures?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because these structures are supposed to mobilize and cultivate young people at university level to actively engage.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we need to move away from a symbolic representation to seeing young people and their institutions as engines of transformation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Second thing that we need to look at is that
[SPEAKER_02]: These young people have a civic responsibility.
[SPEAKER_02]: But that civic responsibility is tied to the responsibility of the state and all the actors.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, the state has the responsibility of ensuring that the educational system is right.
[SPEAKER_02]: The state has the responsibility to ensure that these young people are at school, the young people in those parts have the responsibility to learn and become a responsible citizen.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we're talking about leadership here.
[SPEAKER_02]: If we have leaders that set an example that's wrong, it will automatically reflect, so it will go into society.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the richest person in the society is someone that then comes into politics, became an assistant to a minister, and suddenly is driving a lot of people into society.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you expect the young person that's in primary or BSS to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: Aspire.
[SPEAKER_02]: aspire to be a politician and to steal their money and buy a lot with their current celebration.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, as institutions, we are supposed to collectively, states and the young people, transform our youth organizations where the National Youth Council can encode the World Health Organization, National Diligence, and civil strata code, make them into institutions that are complementary to nation involvement.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's the first thing that we are supposed to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we are supposed to work together, the NDBs, the AUs, the governments, to build these youth institutions into formidable entities that are agents of economic transformation and not just for symbolic representation.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the second point that I would want to touch on in this is that whilst young people are
[SPEAKER_02]: There must be a connection between the energy, the exuberance, the innovation of young people to capital.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because that is leadership as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because leadership is not politics.
[SPEAKER_02]: A young person can be a leader in agriculture, a leader in culture, a leader in sports.
[SPEAKER_02]: But how do we ensure that these young people in their aspirations to be leaders in industry, leaders in agriculture,
[SPEAKER_02]: and so forth and so forth, are able to do that, we need to connect them to capital.
[SPEAKER_02]: And in connecting them to capital, that becomes, again, an issue of policy.
[SPEAKER_02]: And governments, multilateral institutions, are also able to work together to prepare these policies that can make that happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you very much, Ben.
[SPEAKER_05]: Now, Tai, I'm going to give you the last word in one sentence.
[SPEAKER_05]: Just one sentence.
[SPEAKER_05]: Otherwise, the AFDB will never invite me back to the solicited discussion.
[SPEAKER_05]: If you could ask African governments and their partners to change one thing, just one thing, to better unlock even the extra potential for jobs, innovation, and inclusive development, what would it be?
[SPEAKER_04]: I think I'm a wordy respondent when I say the notion of integration.
[SPEAKER_04]: Integrate.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: I like that a lot.
[SPEAKER_05]: So ladies and gentlemen, before we finalize the panel, I'm taking away from our conversation three points.
[SPEAKER_05]: Point number one, we need an ecosystem that is embedded in Afrocentric normative values to ensure that our young people can truly engage and link with our diaspora to facilitate and harness their potential for development.
[SPEAKER_05]: Number two, the world in which young people are living is very different from the world in which we are living, we grew up in.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, a PhD student will struggle to get a good job and build a house within the same timeframe within which I did.
[SPEAKER_05]: So, given that, we need to move at a faster pace
[SPEAKER_05]: and stop talking and move to implementation because it's critical for development.
[SPEAKER_05]: And thirdly, the diaspora are ready to contribute.
[SPEAKER_05]: They are just looking for the frameworks and systems that enables them to direct their money in a way that does more than just support their families, but actually support Africa's economic transformation.
[SPEAKER_05]: And we need to build that system to make it work.
[SPEAKER_05]: Those are the three things I took away.
[SPEAKER_05]: The conversation was rich.
[SPEAKER_05]: There was so much more in it.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I hope you will grab our three excellent panelists for follow-up conversations during the coffee break.
[SPEAKER_05]: So can I ask you to join me in giving them a resounding round of applause for the great knowledge they shared with us.